so for the first time in our history um
people are coming for the mouse bro
oh this is big this is actually really
interesting yeah yeah yeah so scarlett
johansson
uh sued uh disney
yes she sued disney and uh i think also
emma
watson emma stone emma stone was
considering suing disney as well
they're suing disney because disney
placed their movies
i imagine cruella with emma stone and uh
black widow with uh scarlett johansson
on disney plus as well as a theatrical
release when they're both promised
contractually
for only theatrical releases now disney
is going hey there's a pandemic
[ __ ] ain't going to the movies
like they used to
so we're gonna do both now that hurts
emma
stone and it hurts scarlett johansson
because they get a piece
of the theatrical ticket sales they
don't get a piece of disney's
uh subscriptions and i think you had to
pay money to watch it on disney plus it
wasn't just a subscription correct so
they're looking at disney like
hey yo yeah like give me a piece of that
bread like if you charging money for
people to see this i don't even [ __ ]
with us in the theater or not
and i think they're completely
reasonable and i think it's a scumbag
movie on disney
and disney's response was basically like
they included scarlett johansson's
uh yeah these callus responses a
pandemic we paid her 20 million dollars
and they threw the 20 million in there
hoping people would be like this [ __ ]
got 20 million what's she complaining
about
and that's true and people will say that
yeah but keep going but you violated a
contract
if you violated the contract and you
charged us if they made it for free
you could say hey she's callous if you
charged us when we couldn't go to the
theater and i got to watch on a smaller
screen in my house
and i don't get the movie theater
experience you're just as callous yeah
you know it's funny sorry sorry go go no
i mean if the deal is 20 million but it
was supposed to be 40
like she got half the money and what's
so [ __ ] manipulative of of disney's
side
is um knowing that people will see a
number like that so astronomical a
number they might never make in their
life and be like why aren't you happy
with that
yeah right and you seem like an
ungrateful
[ __ ] when you're complaining about a
contract that was breached
by your employer yeah right you guys
came together
made this contract now i understand
every contract has what's called a force
major
clause in it right and that's where they
a uh an ungodly act like a pandemic
comes in
and it can make the contract null and
void or you can switch certain things
but what i find interesting is it's not
like scarlett johansson's going yo you
made a billion dollars
last year or five billion dollars disney
cough it up
like disney i don't think did bad during
a pandemic a lot of people bought up
that disney plus
right they made okay money and if you're
using this as a way to bolster
subscriptions that's great
make more content but if you're charging
people to see the movie
it seems like the right thing to do yeah
is
to continue to pay now they might be
looking at like this
we're going to lose money on this movie
because of the pandemic but we're still
going to pay you that full 20 million we
promise you even though this movie ain't
going to do close to what it was
supposed to do
we're going to live up to our end of the
deal but because it's going to be a loss
maybe not even leader but it's going to
be a loser for us
we're not going to give you any back
ends do you think they go ahead
no you just can't do the right thing you
know i mean like you're in an
infrastructure where you can't
do the thing that is ethically correct
when you have all these shareholders
they're like yo we put up the money for
this movie
let's get our money back like why are we
being nice to some actor we don't care
about actors we don't respect them like
yeah
let's like the infrastructure set up to
do the financially
responsible thing and not the ethical no
but that's so stupid at this timing
because this was supposed to come out a
year ago
and then this was delayed so things like
jungle cruise with disney that are
coming out now like
the rock's not fighting back they know
it's a kind of shared theatrical and
uh on-demand uh in-home experience
so she's a victim of that coming out
that year but these
these streamers are spending for these
losses right now in this battle with
other streamers to get them so for them
to not cough
up if they were going to project that in
a normal theatrical one she would have
made 50 million
as she's been she's already been in nine
[ __ ] marvel movies
they should know a number that would
have said you know what before there's a
lawsuit
yeah you probably would have made 40 or
50 and that
extra 20 30 million dollars is nothing
compared to this little
debacle that's happening right now
because it's going to happen now across
the board with other folks
and the bigger issue is that netflix and
amazon have already developed mechanisms
that
predict okay it's only on netflix these
movies you see these like michael bay
movies and
they basically pay top of market to
orion reynolds and a michael bay
including their buyout on the back end
so they're already anticipating
on that but disney hasn't really come up
with that
what that means real quick so what
they're doing is they're paying ryan
reynolds let's say ryan reynolds
says for me to start a movie and i'm
just making up this number
it's 10 million dollars plus i get a
piece of the theatrical release
piece of the ticket sales what netflix
is doing
in order to get ryan reynolds to do a
movie on netflix is saying we're going
to give you your 10 million
and that piece of what ticket sales
would
be we projected you would get this much
up back based on like
the last five movies or something like
that so they basically come to it
they're not an exact amount but they
come to some agreement so let's say it's
another
5 million or 10 million on top of that
they go we'll give you the 20
so you come to a movie with us and then
ryan reynolds gets to go well i'm not
losing out by doing a movie here and i
get to be on the street and it's agreed
to
up top so you can't really argue after
and say whatever they already this has
already been taken care of
okay okay so disney paramount like
warner plus all these things they're
still just in the let's get subscriber
race right now they haven't come up with
this mechanism because they're also
super you know high they want to have a
theatrical release too they want to have
as
many verticals as possible for one movie
to have to get their theatrical they
want their
airplane revenue their hotel revenue
their on-demand revenue but they're just
not there yet so
covet is a reaction to this but it's so
[ __ ] stupid to do this because the
person
that backs scarlett johansson her point
agent
is arguably the most powerful person in
hollywood controlling
hundreds of other top stars directors
writers so this is gonna it's gonna
start some real [ __ ] so if he says
sells two of his clients hey don't do a
movie with disney [ __ ] them that hurts
you and i think dove's initial point was
the amount of money they're spending
just to get subscribers this 20 30
million extra you could have placed carl
johanson to shut her up
is such a drop in the bucket just do it
don't deal with the bad pr that's i
assume yeah do you know how much jungle
cruise costs
oh cruise is a 300 million plus
moves crazy without anything for the
size of right how much
how much was a black widow because what
if they had taken a loss on it yeah i
have a feeling that if black widow did
well
scarlett would have gotten her that's
what i'm thinking and i think that black
would have flopped
and i don't think anybody really cares
about watching black widow i mean we
could look at the numbers but like i
didn't
watch it i would never turn it on did
you watch it oh i've seen it
they might have also moments out not a
movie sucked it was trash they might
have also taken a calculated risk and
that like
this doesn't allow her to be in any
avengers movies after this who cares oh
does she get killed in it or something
no i don't know but this like if she's
if she's sue if she's upset and she
causes a [ __ ] dust up about this
all right well i guess she won't be in
any marvel movies that she gets upset
but who cares nobody's gonna miss black
widow
i think they might have calculated that
because black widow and hawkeye
y'all are there and i guess it's kind of
cool but like i don't give a [ __ ] i
don't want hawkeye to have his own movie
y'all are
i barely got super powers yeah i mean
black widow is a good negotiator
all right [ __ ] the thing at this point
like marvel movies are just like you
need to watch them to understand the
full story it's like every movie is
gonna have
something that you have to see so you
can understand the whole
rest of the whole series and [ __ ] like
that and so like right now they're
setting up for the [ __ ] universe
because the universe is about to split
in a bunch of different timelines
so now they'll be able to bring back
captain america or no iron man
and captain america like they can bring
back anybody who's died now because
there's more time left yeah
this is saying that this black widow
costs i hate that
what is that thing that it's a
multi-universe yeah but it's a device
uh called a deus ex machina or something
like that
it's like some literary device where an
act of god
propels the protagonist forward instead
of like uh
clever story writing yeah like you know
and uh
what is that movie with the nerds
[ __ ] love uh
stranger things uh no no no no no movie
there's like three of them
uh ghostbusters orcs and [ __ ]
uh lord of the rings the hobbit lord of
the rings like there's one point in time
where like they're at the end of this
cliff and the orcs are about to get them
and all of a sudden these [ __ ] eagles
just come out of nowhere and
take the next destination and it's like
fam why don't you just get the eagles in
the beginning of the movie
and then they take you to where you need
to go like if you always had the eagles
what are we waiting for
they are wrong with someone yeah it's
just it's just lazy writing
and i feel like this multiverse [ __ ] is
kind of lazy it's like okay there's
multiple universes so now we can
get a iron man back in the thing i mean
this was
in the comics written it was all right
yeah long time all right so they've
always been late yes
okay fair enough i mean whatever i'll be
in the movie if they ask
okay it doesn't matter go there and what
universe they asked her
i mean you think i want to be in the
white black panther universe where it's
just white black panther that would be
[ __ ] i don't think that i don't think
they may multiverse there's
unlimited universes white wakanda i want
to be there and i'm
the black family it's called white
panther it is
and i am him i am the white panther dude
i'm going to be in white panther he's
powerful i have powerful power
pants tahala don't take my
[Applause]
yes